[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: All right.
Welcome to lectures
seven and eight.
We're going to talk
about risk preferences.
Hello?
We're going to talk
about risk preferences.
In particular, sort
from the perspective
of expected utility, which
is sort of the classical way
of economics to view this.
This is going to take one and
1/2, perhaps two lectures.
Broadly speaking, we're
going to look at what
does economics usually assume.
How does economics think
about risk preferences,
about choices involving risk?
How do we think about sort of
measuring risk preferences?
What are some of the
implications and what are some
of the limits of risk
preferences in terms of what we
can explain and what
we cannot explain?
And then in the
following lectures
we're going to have an
alternative model of reference
dependence preferences
where essentially you're
going to relax or change
some of the underlying
assumptions on how to measure
preferences related to risk.
Problem set two will be
posted soon-- later this week.
I'm sure you can't
wait for this.
A reminder, late submissions
will not be accepted.
This is always like
a commitment problem
because people come up with
all sorts of good excuses
why they submitted
the problem set late
and then I kind of
feel bad about it.
So I'm here with
committing to not accepting
any late submissions
for whatever
reasons unless you have
sort of a medical excuse
or sort of an excuse notice.
So no my PDF was
corrupted and all sorts
of other good reasons.
I was a student once
as well and I know
students are very creative.
We will post previous problems
sets, midterms, and finals
for you to practice overall.
I think of the problem
sets less of a way
for testing you or testing
sort of whether you can do it
or not, but rather as a way
for you to practice things,
whether you have understood
the materials in parts
of the past problem sets.
And midterms and finals will
sort of help you with that.
As usual, please ask
questions on Piazza
or come to office hours.
So what we're
going to talk about
is, broadly speaking
risk aversion.
How do economists think
about choices involving risk?
Then again, I sort of outline
sort of the very simple
or the basic model of--
main workhorse
model of economics--
is to think about choices
involving risk, which
is the expected utility model.
We're going to then
think about how do we
measure risk preferences,
the underlying preference
parameters that sort of
are embedded in this model.
We're going to lead then
to some absurd implications
in particular.
So discrepancy-- how people
tend to think about small scale
and large scale risk aversion.
What I mean by that--
essentially small gambles that
involve a few dollars versus
really large scale choices
that involve
thousands of dollars.
And what I'm going to show you,
very similar to some degree
to how we think about time
preferences where the typical
exponential discounting model
cannot explain both short run
and long run time preference
decisions that people make.
That's just a sort
of a calibration--
really very hard to do.
Similarly, the
expected utility model
has problems with reconciling
small scale and large scale
choices that people make.
I'll tell you that
in more detail.
But in short, the
summary is if people
are risk averse when it comes
to small gambles, that implies
that they're absurdly
risk averse coming
from large gambles if you sort
of take that model seriously.
And so that's kind of like
not really true in reality.
And so then we sort
think about how
to relax those kinds
of assumptions.
OK.
So first let's think about what
kinds of choices and decisions
do in fact involve
risk and uncertainty.
What examples do we
have in your life?
What is risky or what
would involve uncertainty?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Whether
or not [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
Whether or not to get education.
Whether or not to
study and so on.
Because the reward
often is like uncertain.
Right?
You might get a job.
You might not get a job.
You might do really
well in college.
You might not.
And so on and so forth.
So the costs-- you might like
it, you might not like it,
and so on.
It's not clear.
So the costs and
benefits are uncertain.
There might be a recession
when you graduate.
And so on and so forth.
So the returns and costs
are both uncertain.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Making
large purchases,
like buying [INAUDIBLE].
Because you don't
know [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, exactly.
You might buy a
house or you might
think about buying or
renting more broadly.
And there it depends
a lot on essentially
what's happening to
the housing market.
If the housing market
goes up or down,
the choice to buy a house versus
renting is very different.
Right?
So if the housing market
goes up, most likely
you should probably buy a house.
If the housing market
actually happens to tank,
the [INAUDIBLE] [? at ?]
[? least ?] it's a bad idea
to do so.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? renters ?] insurance.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So the two choices
that we have so far
were essentially
choices involving
risk where you
sort of essentially
decide to do something
where the outcomes are
uncertain or risky in some way.
Now, what you're
saying, in some sense,
is like, a bunch
of other choices,
potentially, are risk
mitigation strategies.
So you have, essentially,
certain risk in your life.
And you have choices
where you could say,
I could buy insurance.
Or I could sort make other
choices that mitigate or reduce
the risk that I'm exposed to.
And one sort of
canonical example of that
is purchasing any
type of insurance
but, in particular, renter's
insurance, as you mentioned.
Yes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: For farmers, the
crop they choose to grow.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, so
essentially, call that--
in development in particular,
or development economics
in particular, there's lots of
issues of production choices
that people make.
This could be like what crops
to grow, whether you should
buy a machine, whether you
should start a business,
and so on.
So there's all sorts
of choices in terms
of what business to go into,
what kinds of specifics,
what product to sell
if you have a business.
And in the farmer case,
what crops should you grow?
Should you buy fertilizer?
Should you use other inputs
and so on and so forth.
Should you do
[INAUDIBLE] there's
a bunch of different other--
should you intercrop?
There's a bunch of
different other choices
that you could make that
essentially involve risks,
because the outcome,
essentially, is uncertain,
because essentially, the
season might be good or bad.
In the farmer's case,
if you, for example,
purchase fertilizer
or a certain--
for example, you could purchase
or use drought-resistant crops.
Of course, if
there's no drought,
then that's not
really that helpful.
But if there's a drought,
that's really high return to do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Creating an
investment portfolio.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Creating a--
AUDIENCE: Investment portfolio.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah,
so investing your money
into a different-- in the
stock market or in other sort
of bonds or the like--
how should you invest the money?
That's kind of related,
to some degree,
to the renting versus
buying a house.
You can think of buying as
a house as one asset, one
potential very sort of illiquid
asset that you could buy.
Similarly, you could buy stocks.
You could buy bonds.
You could keep just
cash and so on.
And there, that very
much depends on,
the return depends
on things that
are out of your hand,
which essentially is just
what the stock market might do.
So I think once you
think about choices
involving risks, essentially
almost any choice
in your life actually is risky
to some degree or uncertain,
ranging from going to
college, doing problem sets,
studying for exams.
Which exams should
you study for?
Which questions are
people going to ask?
Health decisions-- should you
invest in your health or not?
For a lot of diseases
that people might get,
it's often very uncertain.
So even if you're smoking
a lot, not every smoker
falls sick or the like.
No, just the risk of cancer
and other diseases increases.
That sort of
financial investments,
dating choices, and
so on and so forth--
even friendship choices
are, in some sense, risky.
If you want, riding a bicycle--
that's very sort
of small choices--
wearing a helmet versus not.
Essentially, almost
anything in your life,
if you think about what
are the outcomes, what
are the different
choices that you have,
and what are the outcomes
associated with those choices,
almost all of those choices
are associated with uncertainty
and a sense of you're
not quite sure.
Is the return going
to be high or low?
Then as I said before,
in addition to that,
there's sort of risk mitigating
strategies and a sense of you
have a lot of choices
in a lot of issues
that are associated with risk.
And now you can choose
to reduce your exposure
to risk by purchasing
insurance or, for example, also
by avoiding certain
behaviors, right?
So if you're worried about
being robbed, for example,
in a certain part
of town, you might
choose to go through
that part of town.
And that's a risky thing to do.
Or you can have risk mitigating
strategies where you just
don't leave your house, or
just go in different ways,
or just never go into certain
areas, which essentially
are ways to protect
you, to reduce your risk
exposure overall.
Any questions?
OK, so now let me
sort of just tell you
three broad, stylized facts that
we're going to try and explain
or try to tackle.
And that's kind of what
economics is trying to do.
So the first question is--
the first thing
that comes to mind
when you think about
economics and modeling choices
involving risk is risk aversion.
How do we think
about risk aversion?
Or what is risk aversion?
Why are people averse to risk?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Risk aversion
is the tendency
to avoid bets that are more
risky, even though they
will still ostensibly
benefit you the same.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Mhm.
So one-- you said, essentially,
if there are certain bets that
involve risk, where the expected
values or an expectation
you're going to do pretty well--
perhaps better than some safe
outcomes--
people tend to avoid
those kinds of bets.
And that we might
call risk aversion.
So that's exactly right.
But now, why are
people doing that?
What are the underlying
reasons for that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Potentially
involved is
loss aversion, which
in the readings,
I believe, some
studies by [INAUDIBLE]
and others mentioned that,
showed that we had aversions
specifically to losing
money or utility
rather than risk
in and of itself.
But that might be wrong.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one part would
be to say, people
might sort of lose or gain
money in certain gambles.
And what you're saying
is, essentially, people
might not treat the losses the
same as they treat the gains.
And then you might sort
of decline certain gambles
or certain risks.
You're just worried about losing
out, and you put a lot of value
on that.
That's exactly right.
We're going to talk about this
next week in a lot more detail.
But what are some other
reasons why people might not
want to engage in risk?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'd rather be
definitely OK than either
[? to ?] [? the ?] [? point ?]
between super successful
or die.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Mhm.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
diminishing marginal utility,
[? maybe. ?]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one part is-- and
that's exactly how
economists think about this--
is diminishing marginal utility.
That's to say, if
you're really poor,
getting your first dollar
has really high value
to you-- the reason
being that now,
essentially, otherwise
you would starve,
or you can't eat and so on.
The value of whatever you
purchase with that dollar
is really high, because you
just have nothing otherwise.
Now, if I give you a
million dollars and then
another dollar, then essentially
the additional dollar
that I give you
after the million
is just not doing very much.
So the marginal utility
of that dollar is low.
And that's sort of diminishing
marginal utility of wealth.
That's exactly how
economists talk about this.
We're going to get back to
that in a lot of detail.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think if
you look a little more
at extreme examples, [INAUDIBLE]
if I lose so much money,
I won't be able to afford
my expenses or something.
So it doesn't matter what
is [? created ?] [? by ?]
[INAUDIBLE] lose
a lot [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So there might be sort of
certain minimum standards,
in some sense, that people
have over their outcomes.
Or you say, for
example, you really
want to have a place to sleep
or you want to have some meal.
And essentially, if you're
below that threshold,
essentially your marginal
utility anywhere below that
is really high,
because you really want
to get over that threshold.
And so you might avoid
certain choices or investments
or the like.
If there's even a
small chance of getting
below your threshold, you
might be really averse to that.
But what are some more
perhaps psychological reasons
why people don't like risks?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? potential ?] [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Mhm.
So that's right.
That's what people do.
We're going to also
talk about that.
But why do people
not like the risk?
Or some people like,
actually, risk.
But what is the issue about
having a lot of exposure?
Why do people purchase
insurance, for example?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Some amount of
uncertainty [INAUDIBLE]
[? risk ?] [? aversion, ?]
[INAUDIBLE] the higher
the uncertainty of the
outcome, [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So there's one part
that's what you said,
which is there's diminishing
marginal utility of wealth.
And this is exactly how
we're going to model this
and how economists
think about this.
However, there's
other things involved,
which is just things like
anxiety or uncertainty.
People might just not--
suppose a storm is coming up.
I might purchase insurance.
And if I purchase insurance,
like flood insurance,
or the like for a house,
I might just feel much--
I might sleep better at
night and so on and so forth.
I might just feel
better about concerns--
or like health
insurance, for example,
might lower anxiety and so
on, because people are just
not worried constantly
about like falling
ill or like disasters happening.
And that's beyond
potentially any
diminishing marginal
utility of wealth.
That sort of anxiety,
stress, worries, and so on.
Any other reasons?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think even beyond
people wanting to not be
stressed and anxious,
there's also the element
of, if you're buying insurance
to smooth your consumption
between different
states of the world,
it makes it a lot easier to plan
for states after [INAUDIBLE] If
you're--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Well,
that's interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
That's exactly right.
So in some sense, if
you have insurance,
if you reduce risks in
the states of the world,
you can sort of,
essentially, exclude a bunch
of bad states of the world.
For example, suppose you
buy health insurance,
suppose you have flood
insurance, and so on.
A lot of bad things
that might happen you
might be able to deal with.
And you don't have
to necessarily
have a contingency plan
of what if I fall sick
and then go bankrupt, and
all sorts of other bad things
happen.
Or what if I--
there's flood insurance.
I can't pay the
bills and then have
to leave my house and so on.
So essentially, it
makes planning easier,
in part because it's just
sort of easier in the mind.
People feel more comfortable.
And part-- it's actually
computational or just easier
to do.
So I added some reasons here.
There's a bunch of
different reasons.
I think it's important to
understand that economists have
modeled risk aversion
as diminishing
marginal utility of wealth.
That's a very simple
way of doing this.
It captures a lot of things,
but perhaps not all of them.
And so here's some
reasons that I mentioned.
Sort of contingent
planning becomes
harder if you have risk.
That's what Maya just said.
People are worried or
stressed or anxious when
they have lots of uncertainty.
People might feel regret
over missed opportunity.
That's like, if I offer you
some insurance right now,
and you might say, well,
it's actually unlikely
that anything bad happens.
But in case something
really bad happens
and you had the chance to
actually avoid it, then
you might feel particularly bad
not just because the outcome is
bad, but because it
offered it to you
and you didn't accept it.
There's sort of disappointment
relative to expectations.
This is essentially getting into
territory of losses and gains.
When people have
certain expectations,
they have an expectation to have
a certain income and the like.
Now, if bad stuff happens, they
fall below those expectations
and perceive those
outcomes then as losses
compared to the status quo or
the expectations that they had.
Again, economists think
about this as diminishing
marginal utility of wealth.
That's a very simple
way of modeling this.
And we're going to see kind of
what the limitations of those
are.
Now, I'm going to
show you the three
stylized facts about the world.
And then we're going
to discuss kind
of how to perhaps model that.
So the first one is
essentially very simple.
People are risk averse
in various ways.
And one sort of basic fact
is that lots of people
buy insurance.
People are willing to pay
to purchase insurance that
gives you essentially money
or an expectation less money
than you pay, right?
So fair insurance,
as economists would
model is or think
about it, is to say
if I purchase insurance
that pays you the expected
value of the insurance.
So if I pay a premium
for an insurance,
there's a probability of
something bad happening
and then sort of a loss or some
insurance payment that I get
in case something bad happens.
Fair insurance would be
the premium is essentially,
in expectation, the same as the
expectation of the loss, which
is the probability
of the loss occurring
and the actual payment that
I get from the insurance.
Of course, the insurance
industry wants to make money.
So the insurance industry
will not offer fair insurance,
but less than fair insurance.
Essentially, there's a price
for purchasing insurance.
Lots of people are willing
to pay for insurance.
People are willing to pay
money to get insurance
to reduce the risk
or the exposure
to risks that they have.
There's social security
in various ways
where essentially people
sort of insure themselves
or society insures them for old
age or not being able to take
care of themselves.
You could argue
that's perhaps also
due to present bias or
other paternalistic reasons.
But surely like
society, in some sense,
is helping people
insure themselves
against potential states
of the world where
they might be in need.
There's very sort of other--
sorry-- institutions,
including sort
of extended families, informal
insurance in developing
countries, sharecropping,
and so on and so forth.
What's sharecropping?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you go multiple
crops at the same time.
FRANK SCHILBACH: No.
That's intercropping
or the like,
but there might be
referred to that as well.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's when the person
rents out their land for you
work on and you get all
the benefits from the land,
but [? they ?] [INAUDIBLE]
[? rent ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So it's essentially these
kinds of arrangement, which
are often somebody has land.
Somebody rents out the land.
And then you have to
pay them something back
and then can keep some
of the output and so on.
And often that's
essentially some way
essentially reducing risk.
So there's various
sort of institution.
But broadly speaking, we
think, in many situations,
people don't like risk.
And they look for ways to
reduce the exposure to risks.
There's also these informal
insurance arrangements,
which are things like
people get together.
And they sort of
help each other.
Whenever something bad
happens, one person
is then being helped
by everybody else.
And that's sort of replacing
some sort of formula
for insurance schemes
and particularly
in developing countries.
Second, risk reduction
has its price.
That is to say people are
willing to take on risk
if the return is high enough.
So another way to
put this is, if you
want to purchase insurance,
usually you have to pay for it.
The insurance industry
makes a lot of money.
Put differently, people are
willing to take on some risk
if things get cheaper, right?
For example, if you
think about buying a car,
you could buy a super
safe car with all sorts
of safety features.
Not everybody does that.
The reason is because
cheaper cars are less safe.
Cars are cheaper.
So you're might
just sort of willing
to take on some risk in some
situations for some price,
right?
When you think about
starting a restaurant,
restaurants essentially
fail all the time.
Yet people are always
sort of willing to do it.
Presumably, the reason is
because if you actually
succeed, you're going to
make quite a bit of money.
So if there's a high
expected return,
people are willing
to take on some risk.
People put in money
into the stock market,
so they increase
their risk exposure.
The reason why they do that is
because, in expectation, they
make quite a bit of money.
But of course, that
often entails risk.
So one way to think about the
entire sort of finance industry
is risk intermediation.
Essentially, there
are some businesses
that have a lot of risk.
And that risk is sort of
offloaded to investors.
And the investors
accept that risk.
They say, I'm willing
to take on that risk,
but only for a good return.
So I'm not going to
take on risk from you
if I'm not, in
expectation, making money.
But often, essentially,
there's a trade off between.
And this is-- well, if you've
taken finance classes and so
on, that's kind of obvious.
There's a trade between
risk and expected return.
In what situations
are people actually
willing to take on risk
for its own sake or just--
so I told you people
are risk averse.
And that's true in
most situations.
But where are people actually
willing to take on risks?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] casino?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
Lots of people
actually go to casinos.
And here, the expected return
is actually a negative.
You know, you're going
to lose money on average.
Unless you're sort of a smart
MIT student who can count cards
in poker or something,
you're going
to lose money essentially.
So there must be some form of
some preference or some desire
to take on risk in some
situations because you cannot
just-- this is not like
investing in the stock market
where, on average, you're
going to get money.
If you go to the
casino, on average
you're going to lose money.
Now, you could say it's
so much fun and so on.
There could also be addiction.
There could be also
self-control issues and so on.
Or there could be something
about people's beliefs
or preferences that induce
them to take on risk.
But notice that's different
from what we discussed before.
That's not really consistent
with risk aversion
because people choose to
increase the risk that they're
exposed to.
Any other-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Buying
lottery tickets.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
People are buying lots
of lottery tickets.
Similar, they're doing
lots of sports betting.
And again, what you're doing
here is, to be very clear,
on average you're
going to lose money
and that you're going to
increase risk or the exposure
to risk.
And there's some questions
on why people are doing this.
We're going to get back to this.
We're going to not
talk about this today,
but I sort of want to flag that.
While people are
risk averse in many,
in almost, nearly all
situations of the world
of important choices
that you encounter,
there are some choices where
people are, in fact, exposing
themselves to risk in
addition to exposure to risks
that actually has
high expected value.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So now, we're going to talk
about the expected utility
and sort of how do economists
think about how should we
behave.
And that's a normative model,
how the economists think
about how people should
behave when it comes
to choices involving risk.
So what is expected utility?
What does the model assume?
Or what is it about?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's the
utility of each state
of the world multiplied by
the probability of that state
of the word occurring.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So the assumption
here is there's
different states of the world.
There's good things and
bad things may happen.
You might get a job.
You might not get a job.
You might get a good grade,
bad grade, and so on.
You can sort of partition
the world or anything
that's going to
happen in the future
into different
states of the world.
We can associate a
utility, so an outcome,
and an associated utility with
that state of the world, right?
If you get a good job,
you get a high income.
And if you don't
get a job, you get
a low income or
whatever or unemployment
insurance or whatever.
And there are certain utilities
associated with these outcomes.
Expected utility,
now, is essentially
say, OK, now for each of
these states of the world,
there's a probability of the
state of the world happening.
And I'm going to use essentially
the weighted average, which
essentially is weighting each
state with their associated
probability and then
using the associated
utilities for each state.
And the expectations
of those utilities
is what's expected utility.
And that's very complicated.
I'm going to sort of get
[? to where ?] [? that ?]
[? is ?] said in more
words than necessary.
Let me sort of get back to this.
So first, the thing about
expected monetary value--
so suppose there's a gamble.
And this is not a
very simplified.
There's a gamble.
I'll call it G over two
states of the world.
State 1 occurs with probability
p and yields monetary payoff x.
State 2 occurs with
probability 1 minus p
and yields monetary payoff y.
Now, the expected
monetary value--
now, this is not
expected utility.
This expected monetary value.
This is how much money you get
in expectation-- is essentially
just the weighted average
of those two things sort of
weighted by the probabilities.
So that's p times x
plus 1 minus p times y.
That's just the expected
value of how much money you're
going to get from this gamble.
Now, this is just a
definition of fair gamble.
And this is what economists
tend to use a lot.
A fair gamble is
one with a price
equal to its expected
monetary value, right?
So if I ask you would you
like to take this gamble,
you're going to ask kind
of, is this a fair gamble?
Essentially, that's
just asking about is
it paying the expected value
of this in terms of money.
I put monetary in parentheses
because I could also provide
you a fair gamble of apples.
And then it would just be
the expected value of apples.
That would be also a
fair gamble potentially.
Now, what's the expected
utility of this gamble?
Well, now, you need to
have a utility function
for each of these outcomes.
So if my utility
function is u of x,
this kind of how much utility
I get in the state of actually
getting x or y.
So-called xi is where i
is the state of the world.
So essentially, now,
it's the weighted average
of p i times u of xi, so in
this case, p times u of x
plus y minus p times u of y.
Any questions on this so far?
And so when you now think
about evaluating gambles
using an expected utility,
if your utility function
is linear, then you're
going to essentially decide
the same way as if you were
just evaluating the expected
monetary value, right?
And if not, if the utility
function is concave and convex,
then essentially people are
potentially risk averse.
So how economists think
about expected monetary value
is the history of
that used to be,
the first theory that
people wrote down was,
this was a model how people
thought people should behave.
There was a normative model
that people wrote at some point
and said, rational
people should essentially
maximize monetary
payouts, which is
say, if the expected monetary
value of a certain gamble
is high, you should accept it.
Or if it's higher
than its price,
then you should accept
it, otherwise not.
Now, it turns out that,
in practice, that's
not descriptively accurate.
That's just not how people
behave on the world.
And in fact, and the
reason being that people
are risk averse in
most situations.
When using, now, the expected
monetary value, essentially
they use the
expected money value
as a definition for
risk neutrality.
If somebody is risk
neutral, if somebody doesn't
care at all about risk
in some situation,
that person essentially just
is maximizing the expected
monetary value, right?
So a decision
maker is-- and this
is a definition-- is risk
neutral if, for any lottery G,
she is indifferent
between G and getting
the expected monetary
value G for sure.
And so the decision maker is
risk neutral if the utility
function is linear, OK?
Essentially, the more
money you get, then there's
no diminishing marginal
utility of money.
Now, what's risk aversion then?
A decision maker is risk
averse if, for any lottery G,
she prefers getting the expected
monetary value G for sure
rather than taking
G. And the person
is risk loving if
the person rather
has the lottery
than the expected
monetary value for sure.
These are just definition.
That's just the way how
economists think about risk.
That's just definition,
defining how
we think about risk aversion
and risk lovingness if you want.
Now, let me give you just
a very simple example.
Suppose a person with wealth,
$10,000 is offered a gamble.
The gamble is you can gain
$500 with a 50% chance
and lose $400 with a 50% chance.
Will you accept this gamble?
How do we do this now?
Suppose I'm just maximizing
the expected monetary value.
What am I going to do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You take [INAUDIBLE]
something [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to just look at what's my
expected monetary value
of accepting your
lottery, which is
0.5, which is the probability
of a loss times 9,600.
This is 10,000 minus the 400
that I lose plus 0.5 times
10,000 plus 500,
which gives me 10,050.
If I reject the lottery,
I'm just where I am before.
Now, the risk neutral
decision maker
will reject the gamble,
in fact, irrespective
of the initial wealth.
Because, essentially,
everything is linear,
so you just drop out the wealth.
You can just look at what's
the expected value regardless
of how much money
the person has.
AUDIENCE: So you mean
[INAUDIBLE] [? accepting ?]
[INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, sorry.
That's a typo.
Yes, sorry.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah.
So exactly, the
expected monetary value
is higher than the status
quo, so you accept the gamble.
And that doesn't depend
on the initial wealth.
OK.
So now, what's the expected
utility maximizer do?
And how does an expected utility
maximizer think about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In their
calculation, rather than
weighting the 9,600
and the 10,500,
they'll weight
the utility value.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So now, we need the
utility function.
What's the utility of 9,600,
the utility of 10,500,
and the utility of 10,000?
Now, will she accept the gamble?
Well, now, it
depends essentially
on the utility function.
What's the shape of that
utility function look like?
In particular, it
depends on the concavity
of the utility function.
So what do I mean by the
concavity of the utility
function?
This is concave function.
What do I mean by that?
What's the definition?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one definition is a second
derivative is negative.
That's exactly right.
That's true if the function
is twice differentiable.
We have a slightly
different definition
that's slightly more
general because it doesn't
depend on differentiability.
But essentially, it's to say
it's the following definition,
if the utility of a convex
combination of two outcomes--
I'm going to tell you
about this in a second--
is larger than the convex
combination of the utility
of those outcomes.
What do I mean by that?
Suppose you have an outcome
x and a utility associated
with that that's u of x.
Suppose you have an
outcome y and a utility
of u of y associated with that.
And now, suppose you have a
convex combination of x and y,
which is just p is a
probability of p times x
plus 1 minus p times y.
That's in the middle of x and y.
So I take a weighted average
of x and y that adds up to 1.
Now, if I have the utility
associated with that convex
combination, that's u of
px plus 1 minus p times y.
That's just the utility
associated with that.
Now, if I draw a line
between those two graphs
and look at what's the
convex combination of p,
so what's p of u of x
plus 1 minus p of u of y?
That's essentially
the weighted average
of the utilities
associated with x and y.
Now, the question
is, is the average
of the utility of
the average higher
or lower than the
average of the utilities?
Can somebody explain this in
words of what I just said?
Or what do I mean?
Can somebody repeat this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I mean, technically,
we're just trying to see if you
take two points in the
[INAUDIBLE] and draw a line
between them, would the line
be [? below ?] [? the curve? ?]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
Is the line above
or below the curve?
In this case, the line
is below the curve.
Now, what that means is,
if I give you two outcomes
and I say, would
you rather have--
you could have x and
y, or would you rather
have the some weighted
average of x and y?
Now, the question is, what's
the utility associated
with this average of x and y?
That's the thing that you see
here on the left upper side
is u of p of x plus
1 minus p times y.
That's essentially the utility
of the weighted average.
Is that larger or smaller
than the weighted average
of the utility, which is the
thing that I show you here
below?
And what you see is,
in this case-- and this
is because the line is
exactly as I say-- it's
below the utility function.
If the line is below the
utility function, that
means essentially that the
utility of the weighted average
is higher than the weighted
average of the utilities, which
means essentially the
function is concave.
And that means essentially
that the person
is risk averse, as we call it.
You'd rather have the average
than the spread of the two
outcomes.
Any questions on
this or comments?
OK.
So you can look
at this in detail
but essentially it's
a simple definition.
So now, expected utility says
essentially the following.
It says a risk averse person
rejects all fair gambles.
And again, fair gambles
are gambles that pay you
the expected monetary value.
And the reason why
that person does
that is because the
expected utility
is lower than the utility of
the expected monetary value.
Essentially, as
you just said, it's
because the straight line is
below the utility function.
And that's essentially exactly
the same definition here.
Therefore, a risk
averse person who
has a concave utility function
rejects all fair gambles.
Now, what does expected
utility theory then say?
Well, it says risky options are
valued by doing three things.
One is you have to define
utility over final outcomes.
And this is sort of getting back
what you were saying earlier.
People might be worried about
losses or gains or the like.
We're assuming all of this away.
We're just saying, their final
outcomes-- how much money you
have, what grades you have,
how many kids you have,
and so on, these
are final outcomes,
things that sort of where an
absolute value is defined.
There's a utility associated
with those outcomes.
It's not about you
expected more money
or less money or the like.
That's completely irrelevant.
We're just looking
at final outcomes.
How much money do you
end up actually getting?
And we're associating
some utility with that.
That's assumption
number one, or that's
the first thing one does.
Second is you weight these
utilities for each outcomes
by its probability.
Essentially, we know
what the probabilities
are for each of those outcomes.
We're going to take the weighted
average of these utilities.
And then we sort
of adding them up.
And then by adding
them up, essentially we
can evaluate all
sorts of lotteries.
And then we just
compare those lotteries
either with some
fixed amount of money
or some other lotteries, the
outcomes that we might get.
Now, there's two key
implicit assumptions
that are really important.
One is only final
outcomes matter.
It doesn't matter what
you expected in advance.
you thought you might get.
And it doesn't matter
what you had yesterday.
All of these things
are completely
irrelevant in the simplest
form of expected utility
unless you sort of have
information or the like.
Only final outcomes matter.
And then there is linearity
and probabilities.
That's to say we put weight on
the different types of states
of the world relative to what
the probability of those states
are.
So it cannot be that, if
something is twice as likely,
you should put twice
as much weight on that
in your evaluation
of the outcomes.
It cannot be that this is
non-linear in certain ways.
There's linearity
in probabilities.
Any questions on this?
So now, let me get back
to what I said previously.
What are we assuming away here?
What are the things
that are not in here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So essentially, all the other
things that we said previously
we are assuming away,
for example, things
like anxiety over certain
outcomes, worries, stress,
and so on.
I'm also assuming away regret.
I'm assuming away
the gains and losses.
So essentially,
anything we said before
is essentially
just stripped away
and simplified in
some sense and saying,
we can explain a lot
of behaviors just using
the concavity of the
utility function.
Now, I have one example for you.
And I think, I
encourage, you sort of
for any of these kinds
of assumptions or kind
of functions or things
that you see in economics,
it's worth sort of
looking out in the world
what people are actually
doing and trying to see
is that actually compatible
with people, with behavior
that we see in the world.
And here's sort of one example.
So I actually don't think
this is irrational behavior.
And that's actually
a good example of so
what we might confuse
with irrational behaviors.
So I guess what we see is
that expected utility has
a lot of trouble explaining
this behavior, right?
Because essentially, you spent
like $5 on those lotteries.
I'm offering you $10.
So you get twice
as many tickets.
So your probability of
winning will be twice as high.
Presumably, you prefer
winning or losing.
So, therefore, you
should obviously
take that deal unless
there's some transaction
costs and the like.
People are not doing that.
The main reason that's
mentioned here is regret.
Now, what the person
was saying here
is these are perhaps
irrational decisions.
I actually don't
think that's right.
Essentially, it's just we cannot
rationalize the decision that
we see with expected utility
in the sense that it looks like
the person behaves
in irrational ways,
but the person may just
have regret aversion,
something that essentially is
not in the utility function.
We sort of modeled
it in the wrong way.
And sort of, by
not capturing this,
we might miss certain behaviors.
Now, we're going to talk a lot
about-- not about lotteries
right now.
We're going to get back to
this a little bit in terms
of why people engage in risk.
But I just want to be clear
on what we're assuming here.
We're assuming a
lot of stuff away,
and I want you to
be aware of that.
There's another
question which actually
the question or the video did
not sort of try to tackle,
which is why are people
playing these lotteries
in the first place.
Why engage in the lotteries
in the first place?
In some sense, that
wasn't clear either.
Again, we're going
to get back to that.
But the point of the
video was to show you
that, in some sense, these are
a bunch of assumptions that are
in the expected utility model.
Not all of these
assumptions are right.
And you know, we want to
be sort of aware of that.
But let me sort of just
summarize what I just told you.
And this, in some sense, is
recap of 14.01 if you want,
which I think in part you
also discussed in recitation.
Or there's like a
handout from 14.01
that you can look at to
study it in more details.
So many important
economic choices
involve risk and people are
risk averse in many contexts.
The expected utility
model is a workhorse model
of the economics
for studying risk.
And the way it's done
is, essentially, one
takes the weighted average of
utilities from final outcomes.
That's what matters
for assessing outcomes.
OK.
And so, now, we're
going to see, OK, now
taking that model
very seriously, what
can be explained?
And what are perhaps
the limits of doing so?
And sort of risk
aversion comes solely
and exclusively from the
concavity of the utility
function.
There's no other
reasons to avoid risk.
Then essentially your
utility function is concave.
OK.
So now, how do we measure risk?
And that's, again,
sort of definitions
that economists use.
When you think
about risk aversion,
how do you measure this?
Well, you measure it essentially
through the concavity
of the utility function, which
is, as you were saying earlier,
it's coming from the second
derivative of the utility
function.
There's two main measures
that economists use.
There's sort of the
absolute or the coefficient
of absolute risk aversion.
We call that r.
It's essentially taking
the second derivative,
which tends to be negative.
So we take the negative of that.
We scale it by the
first derivative.
That's essentially to
make it insensitive to
if you multiply the utility
function by a constant.
Presumably, that doesn't change
anything to your choices.
So you risk aversion
should not change.
And, therefore, we sort
of have to normalize
or we divide by the
first derivative.
A second version of that,
or an alternative version,
is the coefficient of
relative risk aversion,
which essentially is--
we call it-- gamma.
Gamma is x, the
wealth outcome that we
look at times r times the
coefficient of absolute risk
aversion.
It's the elasticity of the slope
of the utility function, which
I've written out here.
And sort of one very
nice property of this--
and again, that's a definition.
There's not much
to argue with this.
This is just how
economists measure this.
One nice property
of this is, if you
look at portfolio
models or the like,
one implications of constant
relative risk aversion, which
I'm going to show you
a function of in a bit,
is that people with constant
relative risk aversion
invest a constant share of
their wealth in risky assets
regardless of their
level of wealth.
That's a main sort of result
from a finance or portfolio
models.
In some sense, that's sort
of irrelevant for you.
These are just definitions
in the sense of,
if you wanted to
measure risk aversion,
this is what economists
have used mostly, OK?
Now, if I give you
this definition,
how would you
actually measure this?
If you wanted to know
my risk aversion,
how would you do that?
And so let me give you actually
a utility function here.
So let me give you actually
two utility functions.
Here's just examples
of one example
of the constant absolute
risk aversion function
that you see here.
Or a Constant Relative
Risk Aversion, CRRA, this
is what we mostly use.
So that's just the
definition of a function
that has the property that
it has constant relative risk
aversion.
You can sort of verify that.
We're going to focus here on
CRRA functions, which are sort
of what economists mostly use.
So now, if I told you this
is my utility function,
my totally function
looks like this,
now how would you
estimate my risk aversion?
AUDIENCE: [? I ?] can give
you two gambles and then
[INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So could you give me
essentially choices
of outcomes that have
essentially some uncertainty
or different risk involved.
And then I'll give
you the choices.
If I say I prefer
one over the other,
can you tell what my gamma is?
AUDIENCE: No.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
What can you tell me?
Or what can you say?
AUDIENCE: I guess you
can say the [? extent, ?]
but maybe not [INAUDIBLE]
value [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
You can put some
bounds on it, right?
So I'm going to show
you this in a second.
But essentially,
if I say I prefer
one option over
the other, you're
going to have gamma on
the left-hand side, gamma
on the right-hand side, and give
you some equations, essentially
some inequality.
And then if you
solve that equation,
you're going to get
some bound on gamma
that sort of essentially
tells you below or above.
Or my risk aversion
must be below or above
a certain number.
What else could we do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [? Ask ?] [? them ?]
[? when they're ?] [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
And that's what's
called the certainty
or-- so the simplest way of
doing that is to say, here's
a lottery between
some gains or losses
or two gains with
certain probabilities.
There's some risk involved.
And then we could
ask you, what's
the amount that makes you
indifferent between receiving
that amount for sure and the
gamble that I'm offering you?
Now, that's called the
certainty equivalent.
Essentially, it's
the amount of money,
if I have a certain gamble,
what's the amount of money
that, if you get it for
sure, makes you exactly
indifferent between that
amount of money for sure
and the gamble, which
is uncertain, right?
So if we then had the
certainty equivalent,
now you could
essentially just back out
what my gamma is by just
solving for gamma that's there.
Let me actually show you that.
There's another thing
that we could do.
What else could we do?
So we said, OK, if
you gamble, choices
between different
gambles, I could ask you
for certainty equivalent.
Now, these are all kind
of lab ways of doing this.
But if you looked
in the real world,
if you try to sort of
figure out in the real world
how are people
making these choices
or choices in the world,
what kinds of choices could
you observe to figure out
what people's gamma is?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you sell
them insurance or an option
to mitigate their risk and
figure out how much they
value that mitigation?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
That's exactly right.
And that's exactly what
we're going to discuss
and what people have done.
Now, it's a little bit
tricky that in usually cases,
if I just ask you what
insurance have you chosen,
it's a little tricky to figure
out what your gamma actually
is because I don't know
what options you had, right?
So what I need is essentially
a choice set between--
suppose I'm selling
you insurance.
In particular, what
I'm going to show you,
I think, next time is
Justin Sydnor's paper,
where people can
choose between-- these
are customers in a certain
home insurance where
people have choices between
different deductibles, right?
And now, I can essentially say,
if I choose a high deductible
versus a low
deductible, essentially
it's implicitly you're
choosing the risk exposure
that you have for price.
So in Sydnor's case, there's
four different options
that people offer to him.
That was essentially
both the choice set,
like what are the choices that
people offered-- in this case,
I guess they're often
offered four choices--
and then the actual
choice that they made.
Again, that's not
going to give you
an exact gamma in terms of
pinning it down exactly what it
is because there's four
different inequalities that you
get from these choices.
But you can actually
bound, as it turns out,
people's risk aversion
pretty well using
those kinds of choices.
Exactly.
So that's what we have here is
certain equivalence, choices
from gambles, and
insurance choices.
So let's start with
certainty equivalent.
So suppose your wealth equals
either to $50,000 to $100,000
each with probability 50%.
Suppose that's
essentially there's
lots of risk in your life.
Either it's 50,000,
100,000, starting
tomorrow you're
going to find out
the chance of that is 50% each.
Now, of course,
that's hypothetical,
but let's suppose
that for a second.
You're expected wealth
then, of course, is 75,000.
Now, what guaranteed amount,
the certainty equivalent,
of the WCE do you find
equally desirable?
If I could make all
of your risk go away
and just say I'm giving
you a fixed amount,
what amount would you choose?
Now, when you do
that, essentially,
if you give me an amount
W, a certain equivalent,
that gives me essentially
an equation, which
is the utility from the
certainty equivalent,
by definition, since
you just told me that,
must be the same as
the weighted average
of the utility of 50,000
and the ultimately
of 100,000 with probability
50% each, right?
And once you do that, now you
get essentially some nonlinear
equation that depends on
gamma that you can solve.
Perhaps not in closed form,
but you can essentially
figure out what the answer is
in Mathematica or the like, OK?
Now, as it turns out, now
you can solve for this.
And the implied values of gamma
I've written down for here.
So if you tell me here
70,000, gamma is 1.
If you tell me 66,000, it's 2.
58,000, it's 5.
53,000, it's 10.
51,000, it's 30.
Who would say anything below 10?
Yes, no?
What would you say?
AUDIENCE: By below,
you mean less than 10?
FRANK SCHILBACH: So value
of gamma less than 10, yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for sure.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, for sure.
That seems very reasonable.
If you think about value of
30, if you had a value of 30,
you probably would not leave
the house ever in some sense.
You would not come
to class or something
because you're worried
about some stuff falling
on your head or the like.
Because, again, let me show
you what the lottery was.
The lottery was between 50,000
100,000 with 50% chance.
If you tell me you're
indifferent between that
and 51,000 for sure,
you're essentially
valuing this small increment
coming from 50,000 to 51,209.
That's $1,209.
You value that a lot
compared to the 50% chance
of actually getting $100,000.
So we sort of think that, when
looking at these large scale
choices, economists
often assume, I think,
that people's gamma is
somewhere between 0 and 2, OK?
So somewhere maybe
70,000, maybe even
lower than that,
maybe 66,000, these
are sort of reasonable choices
that we think people are making
or you see people
making in their lives.
Anything above that seems
like it's just not right
because, in some sense,
that's not how people
behave in the real world.
People are comfortable with at
least some risk in their life
when you look at them.
So the broad lesson is that
choices involving large scale
risk suggests that gamma
can't be too large, OK?
Now, second we can say--
OK, so those are
large scale choices.
Now, we're going to look at
sort of small scale choices
using small gambles as
[? Deckson ?] was just
alluding to.
So here's a choice involving
a small scale gamble.
What if you had a 50-50 bet
to win $11 and lose $10?
Who would take that bet?
Who would not take it?
OK.
So suppose you know there's a
question kind of like, follow
those questions, now,
since your utility is not
necessarily linear, we need
to know what your wealth is.
Suppose it's 20,000,
but you can choose
all sorts of other numbers.
And you turn down a
50-50 bet to win--
this is 110 and lose 100.
You could do this for
11 and 10 as well.
What can we learn
now about your gamma?
And this is what I
was saying earlier.
Now, it's essentially, if
you turn down this bet,
it must be that having 20,000,
which is the status quo if you
turn down the bet,
the utility of that
is larger than 50% of 20,000
plus 110 plus 0.5 times
the utility of 20,000 minus 100.
And again, I can sort of then
plug in the utility function
and essentially solve for gamma.
Now, if you solve for gamma--
and some of the
next problem set is
doing some of that--
is essentially
rejecting this bet is implying
that gamma is larger than 18.
Now, 18 is actually
not that large.
But surely, 18 is larger than 2.
And we just sort of
agreed earlier on
that gamma should be
somewhere below 10,
presumably somewhere
around 2 or maybe 1.
So what we get here now is,
when you look at large scale
choices, it looks
like people's gamma is
somewhere between 0 and 2,
perhaps below 5 or something,
but surely not above 10.
When you look at small
scale choices that
seem pretty reasonable--
and many of you
seem to agree that you might
not want to take certain bets.
Maybe you're credit
constrained or the like.
But in any case, it looks like
people's gamma is really large.
OK.
And so, now, the
question is, how do we
sort of reconcile this?
How do we put these
things together?
Now, Matthew Rabin has written a
paper of this and sort of says,
this is not just sort of
an intuitive argument.
This is a paper in
Econometrica from 2000.
But in fact, he sort
of proves that, when
people reject small
scale gambles, that just
sort of implies crazy stuff
for large scale choices,
essentially stuff that just
seems completely implausible.
And essentially, he,
under minimal assumptions,
proves that this doesn't
make a lot of sense.
Now, what do I mean by this is
and what do we learn from this
is that essentially the
marginal utility of money
must decrease extremely
rapidly if you sort of take
this model seriously.
He does this under new
assumptions about the utility
function.
So it's not just
something special case
that he sort of
doctored together
with some special assumptions
of the utility function.
The only thing, in
fact, that he's assuming
is that the utility
function is weakly concave.
OK.
And so here's the example
that was also in your reading.
Suppose there's Johnny, who
is a risk averse expected
utility maximizer
where the utility
function or the
second derivative
is smaller or equal
than 0, meaning
that essentially his utility
function is weakly concave.
Suppose that person turns down
a 50-50 gamble of losing $10
and gaining $11 for
any level of wealth.
That assumption at the end,
for any level of wealth,
is kind of important, but
actually not that important.
You can sort of
relax that as well.
For our purposes, we can
sort of mostly ignore it.
Now, what's the
biggest Y such that we
know Johnny will turn down a
50-50, lose 100, win Y bet?
So here are the answers.
And what's the correct answer?
AUDIENCE: G.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
G. And why is that?
Or can somebody explain
what's going on?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it
because he will reject
this bet for any
level of wealth,
so that kind of
implies that he's not
able to accept
any level of risk?
FRANK SCHILBACH: No, no, no.
I think that's just because,
for the iteration forward
in the proof of
the thing, he needs
to sort make that argument.
But in fact, that's
not essential.
There's some
restrictions to that.
You can prove the same
thing maybe not as
stark in terms of a
result, but this is just
because he's iterating forward.
He needs to sort of
prove the sequence
of utilities that derives.
But it's actually not
necessarily central.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think the paper
argued that Johnny [INAUDIBLE]
implied that the [INAUDIBLE]
[? utility ?] [INAUDIBLE] very
[? rapidly decreasing, ?]
[? which means that ?] between
that he will [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So what's happening
here is that--
so let's sort of
start very simply.
Let's start with
Johnny's first choice
that says he rejects the
bet, which means essentially
on the right-hand side
is utility of status quo,
essentially just utility if w.
On the left-hand side is
50% chance of winning $11
and 50% chance of losing $10.
Now, you can sort
of multiply this
by 2 and rearrange, which
gives you the second line.
Essentially, that says that
the increase in utility going
from w to w plus 11 is smaller
than the increase in utility
going from w minus 10 to w.
OK, that's just the left-hand
side and the right-hand side.
I'm just rearranging terms.
So what that means
is that, again,
like on the left-hand
side, how much
does the utility increase
if I go from w to w plus 11?
Essentially, if I add
$11 from coming from w,
that utility that he values by
at most 10/11-- so each dollar
that he gets on
the left-hand side
is valued at most 10/11 as
much as the dollars between w
minus 10 and w, right?
So if you have $10 on the
right, $11 on the left,
you prefer the right-hand side
over the left-hand side, which
means each dollar must be valued
more on the right-hand side.
Put differently, the dollars
on the left-hand side,
that value is 10/11 of the
dollars on the right-hand side,
OK?
So just to repeat again,
on the right-hand side,
we're adding $10.
On the left-hand side,
we are adding $11
or subtracting-- we're
adding $11 on left-hand side
and we're subtracting $10
and the right-hand side.
Now, since you prefer
the thing or the thing
on the right-hand
side is larger,
that must mean that each
dollar on the right-hand side
is worth more.
It's 11/10 compared to the
dollars on the left-hand side.
Or put differently, each
dollar on the left-hand side
has value 10/11 of each
dollar on the right-hand side.
You can sort think
about this a bit.
But trust me, that is correct.
Now, there's diminishing
marginal utility.
Essentially,
concavity sort of says
that the marginal
dollar at w minus 10
is at least as valuable as
the marginal dollar at w.
That's essentially just simple
assumption of concavity,
essentially just saying, there's
diminishing marginal utility.
So the lower the amount
of wealth that you have,
the weakly larger the
marginal utility is.
So the marginal
utility at w minus 10
is at least as large as
the marginal utility at w.
And that marginal
utility for dollar
is at least as valuable as the
marginal utility at w plus 11.
Now, sort of taken
together, that means
that Johnny values $1 at w
plus 11 by, at most, 10/11 as
much as he values the
dollars at w minus 10.
What does that mean is that
if you go from minus 10
to a plus 11 essentially the
marginal dollar that you get
is worth 10 11th as
much for every $21
that he increases his Wilson.
So I think, given some of
the confused faces I see,
we might do some of
this in recitation.
But this is essentially
simple algebra and using
the minimal assumptions
that I made.
Now, you can do
the same thing as
like if the person
were $21 richer.
So essentially, now, I'm
doing the same thing,
just adding $21 on each side.
I'm doing the exact same thing.
And I'm going to get essentially
the exact same thing.
It's essentially saying that he
values each dollar that he gets
at w plus $32 by, at most, 10/11
to the power of 2 5/6 as much
as he values the
dollars at w minus 10.
So what I'm essentially doing
is I'm iterating forward.
So I know the utility
function is concave by sort
of your first choice.
I know that essentially
[INAUDIBLE] utility
is declining going on one side.
So now, essentially taking
this forward-- essentially
saying, well, for every $21,
you value each dollar by 10/11
as much.
So now, I'm saying,
well, if you had
$21 plus $21 is $42
plus $29 is $63,
your marginal utility must
be really declining very,
very rapidly.
So once you have a lot more
money, then essentially you
just don't care at all about any
marginal dollar that you get.
So you can do this by if
the person was $42 richer.
Essentially, you'd care about
each dollar 5/6 as much.
If it's $420, you care
about it 3/20 as much.
And if you were $840
richer, you care about it
only 2/100 as much.
Essentially, that's to
say-- and this is exactly
as you were saying--
the marginal utility
plummets for substantial
changes in lifetime wealth.
So you care less than 2%
about an additional dollar
when you are $900 richer
than you are right now.
That doesn't feel right,
but essentially it's
a simple implication of
what was just assumed.
There's no magic here.
This is very simple
algebra and using
very simple minor assumptions.
But essentially, it's saying, if
this person rejects this gamble
as we just had, it follows--
and there's sort of complicated
proofs in the paper.
But it follows
that, essentially,
the additional for, if you
give the person $900 more,
the person values
each dollar only 2%
as much as when the
person is $900 richer.
And so then you look
at these consequences.
And you can read this
in the Rabin and Thaler
paper or the original
Rabin paper if you like.
Essentially, you get
these absurd conclusions.
If you look at the
left-hand side,
these are sort of like if an
expected utility maximizer
always turns down certain bets.
On the left-hand
side, it follows
that he also turns on the
bets on the right-hand side.
And we think, you
know, for example,
if I told you losing
$10 or gaining
$11, that seems like
a reasonable thing
to reject perhaps.
That seems like a thing
that one might do.
At least, you guys were
saying that you might do that.
Well, if that's
the case, then you
should also accept or reject
the gamble of losing $100
and gaining infinite
amount of dollars.
And that seems obviously absurd.
And so that can't
be really true.
Now, what's going
on here essentially
is to say is that the
utility function, as it
is an expected utility,
has trouble reconciling
people's small scale choices
and large scale choices.
And it's similar to
what we talked about,
like exponential discounting.
We only have one
parameter here, which
is gamma for both
gains and losses
and for all sorts of scales.
And that parameter is just not
able to fit people's choices
in sensible ways.
It seems to be people
have small scale risk
aversion in some sense.
And it seems to be people are
not incredibly risk averse
for large amounts of money.
And so, now, the expected
utility model cannot match both
of those things.
That's essentially what
the Rabin paper does.
We'll talk about this in some
slower reform in recitation
to sort of go over this.
But in some sense, the
important part here
is to understand the intuition.
And intuition, essentially,
is that, if there's
curvature over very small scales
or over very small stakes,
it must be there's lots
of curvature going forward
over large scales.
And that's just not plausible.
Because, essentially,
then people would just not
value really, really
large amounts.
And we know that people do value
money at least to some extent.
Any questions on this overall?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I guess
[INAUDIBLE] [? mimicked ?]
the [INAUDIBLE].
I guess, does the [INAUDIBLE]
hyperbolic model essentially
almost [? work ?]
[? here ?] where [INAUDIBLE]
to [INAUDIBLE] singular
[INAUDIBLE] if someone tried
to do the long-term,
short-term thing, [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
So what we're going
to do is-- so notice
that, here, he was
not assuming anything
about the utility function.
The only thing he was assuming,
or Rabin was assuming here,
is that the person is
expected utility maximizer
and that the utility
function is weakly, not even
strictly, concave.
Now, what that means is
you can't sort of just
change the functional form.
This is a general proof for any
utility function that you use.
So what you have to do
now is either sort of say,
well, there's some
other assumptions
wrong about expected utility
in terms of weighting
the probabilities or stuff
like that that essentially
can explain the phenomenon.
It could be something about
[INAUDIBLE] aversion and so on.
These seem kind of unlikely.
The most likely
thing-- and this is
what I'm going to talk
about next week-- is
Kahneman-Tversky's sort of loss
aversion framework where you
say, if you put different
weight on gains versus losses,
then essentially you
have two parameters.
You have one parameter about
your risk aversion over gains.
And you have a parameter that's
steers kind of how you feel
about losses compared to gains.
So once you do that, then you
have another degree of freedom.
And you can explain a lot
of [? favors ?] potentially.
But that's kind of the
equivalent of that exactly.
But the difference
here is that it's not
coming through the utility
function, the reason
being that the problem is
actually not the utility
function.
Because as I said, there's
actually no assumption here
that can even be
changed because it's
very general for any
function that you assume,
be it any of the ones that I
just showed you previously.
OK.
So then the last choice--
[INAUDIBLE] doing we'll get
started on this and then going
to finish next time--
is, as your
classmate was saying,
about insurance choices.
So how do we do that?
So this is a very nice
paper by Justin Sydnor,
who's using sort of real
world insurance choices.
And what's very nice about it
is that you might not say, well,
I might sort of say,
well, college students
and lab choices gives
you funky answers.
And you might not
sort of believe
that this is really predictive
of anything in the real world.
So we really want
real world choices
that people make in their lives.
And sort of you might also
worry about demand effects
and about sort of people
behaving a little bit
funny in experiment.
So let's find real world
choices that people have made
and try to see.
Maybe we can estimate
gamma using that.
And so what Justin Sydnor
has is data from a large home
insurance provider.
He has a bunch of
standard policies.
There's a random
sample of those.
So there are 50,000
standard policies.
What he has, importantly,
he has both the options
that people had-- so
what is your choice set?
Here's four different
choices for each person.
And he has then the
choices that people made.
Plus, he has claims that
people made after that.
He has all the new
customers, which
matters a little bit
because, you know,
you might say new
customers are confused.
Maybe the old ones are
the ones that are right.
Now, the key part
here is the deductible
that people were choosing.
What is a deductible?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How much
you'll pay out of pocket
before the insurance kicks in?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So this is expenses
paid out of pocket
before the insurer starts
paying any expenses.
That would be like, if you
had some damage to your house
for some small amount, you would
have to pay that for yourself.
If you have some large
amount of damage,
you have to still
pay the small amount.
And then the insurer
would pay the rest.
And that's usually used to
deter a large number of claims
because you know the
insurance company just
doesn't want to pay
for every $50 of damage
that you might have.
Because that's just
really costly for them
to do for administrative costs.
Now, what Sydnor has is choices
over menus of four deductibles.
And again, as I said, he has
both individual choice set
and their preferred options.
If you only had the
preferred options,
it would be very hard to figure
out kind of what actually--
because you then can't really
say what's the counterfactual.
You don't essentially what
else he could have chosen
or he or she should have chosen.
So you kind of want
to different options
and then sort of the outcome.
And then say, OK, since you
had these different options
available, it must be that you
preferred one or the other.
It must be that you're
risk averse or not.
So here's kind of what
these data look like.
The sample data are deductibles.
OK.
This is, again,
the amount that you
have to pay out of pocket
until the insurer sort of kicks
in and pays for you.
There is the premium,
which is how much you
have to pay every
year anyway regardless
of what anything would happen.
There's sort of, relative to the
$1,000 policy, kind of what's
the premium.
That's to say how much
more money you have
to pay for a certain premium.
So for example, choice
one has a premium of $504.
Choice two has a
premium of $588.
So that's $84 higher.
You pay essentially $84
in premium every year
to reduce your deductible
from $1,000 to $500.
OK.
So what you can do,
essentially, you
can reduce your
deductible at a price.
The price relative to the $1,000
policy is in the third column.
And you see the deductible
on the left-hand side.
So this person is
like policyholder--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you're
comparing their choices,
couldn't it be that they're
just a more risky person and not
necessarily risk averse?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
So that's exactly right.
So there's sort of unobservable
risk that people might have.
I'll get back to that.
But essentially, what you
see is that a lot of people
make very similar choices.
Then on average, people's
risk is relatively low.
So what you're
saying-- essentially,
I need to know your claim rate.
I need to know kind of what's
your probability of actually
having any damages.
And it turns out claim
rates are extremely
low in the sample, the
order of magnitude something
like below 5%.
Or I think it's even lower.
So it cannot be that everybody
is a high risk person.
It can be potentially
that everybody thinks
they're a high risk person.
But, you know, then there's
a different mistake going on.
So what he's
assuming, essentially,
is, on average, it must be that
there's some high risk people
and some low risk people.
But essentially, he's sort
of kind of assuming this away
and sort of saying, look,
on average claim rates
are really low.
It could be that there is some
fraction of really high risk
people.
But by definition,
since they're only
something like 5%
of claim rates,
it can't be that
there's everybody
is a high risk person.
So it must be that there's some
people who behave as if they're
either really risk averse or
as if they think they're really
high risk people.
And this is kind of where
the old and new customers are
helpful for.
Because there are some customers
who have been at this company
for, like, 10, 15 years.
And sort of, there,
you know, you kind of
should know what kind of
risk person you are perhaps.
But that's a great question.
I'll actually get back to that.
OK, so policy holder one,
their home was built in 1966.
He had an insured
value of 180,000.
The menu available for this
policy in the same year
was the following.
And then he has also the
choice on the right-hand side.
You see the policies
that are chosen.
So that person chose, for
example, a deductible of $200
and for a price of
$157 relative to paying
the $1,000 deductible.
Policyholder two, similarly,
sort of chose the first option.
Notice that the price has
changed a little bit in part
because the company
has sort of taken
into account some covariates and
some risk in some ways already.
So the company is kind
of pricing specifically
depending on what your home
value is and maybe the area
and so on and so forth.
But since Sydnor has
all that information,
he can sort of just
take that into account.
Now, what can we now
say about risk aversion?
How can we now sort
of estimate risk
aversion using these choices?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you
know your house is
[INAUDIBLE] and your
[INAUDIBLE] problems [INAUDIBLE]
so then you don't have
to pay [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So what you need to
know is essentially
a number of different things.
You need to know the
deductibles, the premiums
for each option, the claim
probabilities, and the wealth
levels.
I'll talk about
this in more detail.
But essentially, what you can do
is, for each of these options,
you can write down an indirect
utility of wealth function.
You essentially can write
down what's the expected
utility of that option.
And then you can essentially
just put bounds essentially
on if you preferred
option one or option two.
That tells me something
about your gamma.
And so what Sydnor then does
is essentially estimate gamma
using those different choices.
I'm going to go over
that in a lot more
detail and slower next time.